Epis in Arizona
hi Debbie how are you hi Dave hi John I
happen to be looking for free advice so
I've come to the right place yeah we're
gonna give you twice the value Debbie my
question today is about really learning
to trust myself my journey to baby step
six only started at age 50 when I found
myself divorced and without a back-up
plan so I committed myself to your
process completely it felt imperative it
was fear fueled I had blinders on head
down no monkey business and plowed
through it and I'm proud of the fact
that I've made it to baby step six and I
have a healthy emergency fund and I'm
really finding it difficult to lighten
up and when I try to spend money on
myself or relax I this this sense of
fear gets triggered again that I'm going
to flip backwards or begin spending
unconsciously or or you know whatever I
did for the first 50 years that had no
particular goal in mind or understanding
of what I was doing I'm afraid I'll slip
back into that if I if I just even spend
those monthly mad money I put in my
wallet I hold on to that as if it's the
last 50 bucks I have on my heart for a
warrior to rest after the war's over
well put did you grieve your divorce oh
yeah I think deep okay because in Dave
just said it much more succinctly than
then I will but often when we have an
identity that gets pulled out from under
us we immediately dump that identity
into something else and if your identity
as you described it is you got gizelle
intense he became a runner and a fighter
then once you win you didn't start
looking around for other things to fight
and for other things to run from or
instead of running towards things your
whole identities running away from and
so the reason I asked you have you
grieve this yet because what I hear you
saying is you know
trust yourself still and sometimes
against a long-term marriage that you
found yourself with nothing you trusted
a lot and you trusted yourself and I
want you to hear me saying you've got
value and you've proven to yourself that
you're strong you're proven to yourself
that you're a stud and now you have to
give yourself permission to look in the
mirror and say I have value and I can
trust myself now and then go buy
yourself something nice and definitely
resonate yeah and as you're doing that I
mean I think if you look at the facts
the facts as you laid them out to us are
the facts are that you are trustworthy
mmm you're worthy of trusting yourself
because you've done a good job now you
you and on top of that you're so self
aware that one of the reasons you did a
good job was you were scared out of your
dadgum mind and you didn't you you were
running at breakneck speed away from
danger you know and and you're saying
hey I you know and now that I don't have
danger I don't have the light there's no
lying on my heels I don't know how to I
don't know I don't know what to do now
there's nothing to run from and and I'm
a little bit afraid without that fear
that I'll relapse or that I'll do
something stupid and the fact that you
say that out loud means that that one
thing gives you pretty good you know
pretty good insurance you're not going
to do that because you're just
self-aware enough to do that so I think
you're in a really really good place and
then the last thing is the truth is how
were 30 years the other side of our
crash and we still walk with a limp okay
I mean if I start a certain series of
behaviors or sentence structure that
that reminds my wife of the way I did
business when we were building a house
of cards that caused us to lose
everything it activates a scar in her
psyche can you possibly imagine that I
mean if she senses that something
occasionally she just gets these
heebie-jeebies and she's like oh god oh
god
Oh God trauma has no calendar in new
clock yeah but it does it that you know
the scar does heal and it becomes
thicker scar tissue and it's not it's
not as tender 20 years later as it was
20 days later it's not as tender 30
years later it does get better but it's
always there and so you know I have we
have to sit down and take extra care of
communication in our marriage because of
what we went through to say that there's
a scar here so we have this emergency
fund and here's how much money we have
here and you feel like if we're spending
this that we're out of control honey
because she's afraid we're gonna relapse
or something you know it's okay if we
buy this look here so here's what this
is as a percentage of this and there's
all this other money so we're okay okay
okay I can calm down now but she I have
to kind of go back and revisit that
place and and occasionally I caused it
too so it's not just her but I mean part
of this is is you're all what you you
know once you were a single mom for
instance and then you get married later
you you always have this thing of I've
got to be able to survive because I was
on my own once and had to survive and so
you have that in your psyche it's just
there it's part of your experience as
part of who you are it's part of the
beauty of who you are but it's also part
of the the downside of who Sharon and I
are because we still have that scar and
you know any time you go through trauma
it's it's there and it's just as time
goes on but I think you are very bright
and you're very self-aware and I think
you're just fine I think you're worthy
of trusting yourself a it sounds like
she went from trust in a marriage yeah
in a person but then she transferred
that trust to the baby steps and the
next move to make is she needs to
transfer that trust to herself and she
needs to draw a picture of what
tomorrow's gonna look like and what the
next ten years are gonna look like and
stop running from and start running to
yeah and that sounds trite and this
sounds cheesy but now she gets to trust
herself and to write up the new plan and
man giving her resilience in her
strength is gonna be awesome to watch
her not adventure and you know there's a
lot of people right now they're coming
on kovat yeah and and I got the they got
the they got smacked on the nose
financially lost a job in
emergency fund they had they had a
moment and there's you know they're
right this second listening to us and
they're going oh god it's an oh crap
moment you know and and and we've got a
hundred thousand people to this 14-day
free trial on Financial Peace University
in 60 days that's yeah that's an oh crap
moment I got it I got it I don't ever
wanna be here again right you know and
that's what we had when I went broke I
don't know crap I don't ever wanna be
here again you have a never again moment
right you know never again and with the
baby steps do the nerd the nerd word is
scaffolding it gently picks you up it
gives you a plan to follow why you get
your sea legs underneath you and you
start walking taller and more firm and
taller until you rebuild the trust and
baby step seven as so is so detailed it
says build wealth and be generous right
and by then by then you don't need the
scaffolding you realize you were
standing tall yeah